This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Today we have a story that will change the way you think about many things, poverty, loneliness, time, even hunger. It's a tale about the psychological phenomenon of scarcity. It affects nearly everything in our lives and connects people who appear to have nothing in common. The story of scarcity is a story of how not having enough of what you need can become the only thing that matters to you. My name is Brandy Drew. I'm from Detroit, Michigan.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。今天，我们有一个故事，它将改变你对许多事物的看法：贫穷、孤独、时间，甚至是饥饿。这是一个关于稀缺的心理学现象的故事。它几乎影响着我们生活中的方方面面，并将那些看似毫无共同点的人联系在一起。关于稀缺的故事，讲述了当你严重缺乏所需之物时，这种缺乏如何会变成对你而言唯一重要的事情。我叫布兰迪·德鲁。我来自密歇根州底特律。
Brandy Drew has a story that may sound familiar to you. A story of poverty and debt. It's the kind of story that may lead people to quick conclusions, so pay attention to your own. Brandi is now 37. Six years ago her life on Ravel. At the time she ran the Dining Services Department at a senior living facility. She'd been with a company that ran it for more than a decade. One day she made a mistake. I was just in a rush to get home, that was all, because daycare closes at six. I get off at five. It was like maybe a 10 mile drive, busy traffic area.
布兰迪·德鲁有一个你听起来可能会觉得似曾相识的故事。这是一个关于贫困和债务的故事。这类故事很容易让人轻易下结论，所以请注意你自己的判断。布兰迪今年 37 岁。六岁时，她的生活发生了翻天覆地的变化。（注：原文为六年前，此处按语意）当时，她在一家老年生活护理机构管理餐饮服务部。她在那家运营该机构的公司工作了十多年。有一天，她犯了一个错误。我当时只是急着回家，仅此而已，因为日托中心六点关门。我五点下班。开车大概要 10 英里，路段交通非常拥堵。
I knew I had to pick up diapers and the easiest thing for me, I thought would be to pick them up before I pick the baby up. So Brandy stopped at a store, ran in, and grabbed the diapers. She swiped her credit card at the South Checkout Station, and raced out. It turns out she used the wrong card, not her own, but the company credit card. But what's crazy is I didn't realize at that moment, I didn't realize until my supervisor called me in and said, hey, what's this purchase?
我知道我得去买尿布，对我来说最简单的办法，我想就是在去接宝宝之前先把尿布买好。于是布兰迪在一家商店停下，跑进去拿了尿布。她在南侧收银台刷了信用卡，然后冲了出去。原来她用错了卡，用的不是她自己的卡，而是公司的信用卡。但疯狂的是，我当时并没有意识到，直到我的主管把我叫过去说，嘿，这是什么消费？
So has she not said anything? I don't think I would have realized that. Randy carried the card in case she needed to buy dining supplies for work. She'd never had a problem before, never been reprimanded. She thought an apology and an explanation would do. And her response was, well, you know we have to terminate you. And I'm like, no, I didn't know that.
所以如果她没说什么的话？我想我是不会意识到的。兰迪随身带着这张卡，以防她需要为工作购买餐饮用品。她以前从未遇到过问题，也从未受过训斥。她以为道歉并解释一下就行了。而她的回应是，嗯，你知道我们不得不解雇你。而我说，不，我不知道。
Like, can I just pay you back? It was only, what, 12 bucks? And she said, no, in cases like that, you automatically have to terminate the employee. I just cried. I cried for like a whole day because I couldn't believe it. I didn't want to go home and tell my kids what had happened. I didn't want to tell my husband what had happened. I just didn't know what to do at that point.
比如，我能把钱还给你们吗？也就 12 美元吧？她说，不，遇到这种情况，你自动就被解雇了。我只是哭。我哭了一整天，因为我简直不敢相信。我不想回家告诉孩子们发生了什么。我不想告诉丈夫发生了什么。当时我真的不知道该怎么办。
I felt like a failure as a parent because because I didn't provide a good example, even though it was a mistake. Brandy earned more than her husband, so the loss of the job hit hard. She felt like a loser. She tried to bring in money doing odd jobs like cooking takeaway meals, but the stress grew. Brandy and her husband began fighting.
我觉得自己作为一个父母很失败，因为我没有树立好榜样，尽管那只是个失误。布兰迪的收入比丈夫高，因此失去工作的打击非常沉重。她觉得自己是个失败者。她试图通过做外卖烹饪等零工来赚钱，但压力越来越大。布兰迪和丈夫开始争吵。
She had supported him when he'd been laid off a few years earlier, and she'd expected he'd do the same for her. But he felt a layoff was different. He was mad that she'd made his stupid mistake. The final argument was that I left out the house that morning. I was going to job interviews. I had two interviews that day and I didn't purchase toilet paper so when he got home from work that day there was no toilet paper. When I came in with the kids he just immediate started yelling. You can't keep yourself together, you can't do this, you can't do that so I
几年前丈夫失业时，她曾支持过他，她也期望丈夫能这样对她。但他觉得失业是不一样的。他很生气她犯下了这么愚蠢的错误。最后的争吵发生在那天早上我出门的时候。我要去参加求职面试。那天我有两个面试，但我没有买卫生纸，所以他那天下班回家时没有卫生纸。我和孩子一进门，他就开始大喊大叫。你连自己都管不好，这个做不好，那个也做不好，所以我就
walked right back out the door and I never looked back. Without steady employment and a husband to help with bills, Brandy watched anxiously as her household supplies dwindled. She worried constantly about money. To make ends meet, she ordered a new credit card. The day arrived, Brandy tore open the envelope. She grabbed the card and ran out the door. I went straight to Walmart and I bought like a family size of toilet paper, family size of laundry detergent.
直接走出门去，再也没有回头。没有稳定的工作和丈夫来分担账单，布兰迪焦虑地看着家里的物资一天天减少。她时刻为钱操心。为了维持生计，她申请了一张新信用卡。日子到了，布兰迪撕开信封。她抓起卡夺门而出。我直奔沃尔玛，买了一大家庭装的卫生纸、家庭装的洗衣液。
Like I stocked up on things all at once, whether then keeping it handy just in case. So I like maxed it out within the first couple of days that I had it rather than holding on to it for emergency purposes. And in that moment as she was maxing out the credit card on the household supply she needed, Brandy forgot about things that was slightly less pressing. What I didn't think about is what about gas money? I didn't consider what gas would cost. That was like the biggest thing.
就像是一次性囤积了很多东西，而不是以防万一留着备用。所以我在拿到卡的前几天就把额度刷爆了，而不是把它留作紧急备用。就在她把信用卡额度刷光来购买所需家居用品的那一刻，布兰迪把那些稍微不那么紧迫的事情抛到了脑后。我当时没有考虑的是：那汽油钱怎么办？我没有考虑汽油要花多少钱。那才是最大的问题。
It was always hard to have gas. And of course, there was the credit card bill itself. The first two months I paid the minimum payment and then I just stopped paying because I couldn't afford to pay. I didn't pay that card off until I got my text refund the following year. By the time I paid it off, it was over $800 for a $500 card. More and more, Brandy felt trapped by debt.
买汽油总是很艰难。当然，还有信用卡账单本身。前两个月我只还了最低还款额，后来就索性不付了，因为我根本付不起。直到第二年拿到退税，我才把那张卡还清。等我付清时，一张 500 美元的信用卡账单已经超过了 800 美元。布兰迪愈发感到被债务困住。
She no longer had options. It came down to pay the bills or feed the kids. It was just overwhelming trying to juggle all of those things and still maintain a certain state of mind so that my children wouldn't see me struggle. In retrospect, Brandy can see the mistakes she made. If she had made a budget for the whole month, she might have remembered she needed to account for gas. If she had focused on the big picture, she might not have maxed out a credit card she couldn't afford to pay back. Why did Brandy make these mistakes? It's easy to say she was being irresponsible. But
她再也没有其他选择了。归根结底就是付账单还是喂饱孩子。同时应付所有这些事情，还要保持某种精神状态不让孩子们看到我的挣扎，这实在让人不堪重负。回想起来，布兰迪能看到自己犯下的错误。如果她做了一个一个月的预算，她可能就会记起她需要把汽油费算进去。如果她把目光放长远，她可能就不会刷爆一张她根本无力偿还的信用卡了。布兰迪为什么会犯这些错误？人们很容易说她不负责任。但
here's the thing, she had always been careful and conscientious. Did something cause her to behave differently? When you have scarcity and it creates a scarcity mindset, it leads you to take certain behaviors which in the short term help you manage scarcity, but in the long term only make matters worse. When we come back, how the scarcity trap changes the way we think. Stay with us. This scarcity trap changes the way we think. Stay with us. After she lost her job, Brandy fell deeper and deeper into debt. One big reason is that she made a series of decisions that improved her life in the
关键在于，她一直是个小心谨慎、认真负责的人。是什么导致她有了不同的行为？当你面临稀缺，它就会产生一种稀缺心态，这会促使你采取某些行为，这些行为在短期内能帮应对稀缺，但从长远来看只会让事情变得更糟。稍后回来，我们将探讨稀缺陷阱如何改变我们的思维方式。请继续收听。这种稀缺陷阱改变了我们的思维方式。请继续收听。失业后，布兰迪陷入了愈发深重的债务泥潭。一个主要原因在于，她做出了一系列在
moment but made it worse in the long run. She could have used the new credit card only for emergencies, but instead she maxed it out in a couple of days. To understand why she did this, I want to take you to a completely different time and place, because it reveals something important about Brandy's story. It's 1944, World War II is nearing its end. Europe is on the verge of mass famine. Aid workers desperately need guidance on how to bring people back from the brink of starvation. Researchers at the University of Minnesota thought they
当下改善了生活、但从长远来看却让生活变得更糟的决定。她本可以把新信用卡留作紧急情况下使用，但她却在几天内把它刷爆了。为了理解她为什么这么做，我想带大家回到一个完全不同的时间和地点，因为它揭示了布兰迪故事中一些重要的东西。那是 1944 年，第二次世界大战接近尾声。欧洲正处于大规模饥荒的边缘。救援人员迫切需要关于如何将人们从饥饿边缘拉回来的指导。明尼苏达大学的研究人员认为他们
could help. They launched a year-long experiment. As a 2002 documentary made by the University explains, the volunteers were conscientious objectors who still wanted to serve their country. The experiment? The volunteers had to go on a starvation diet. 36 young men, most of them Quakers, men and nights, or Church of Brethren members, moved into the South Tower of the Memorial Stadium, which would be their home for a year. Many took courses at the university, even as they grew thinner and thinner.
可以帮上忙。他们发起了一项为期一年的实验。正如该大学 2002 年制作的一部纪录片所解释的那样，志愿者们都是拒绝服兵役者，但他们仍然想为国家效力。实验内容是什么？志愿者们必须进行饥饿节食。 36 名年轻男子，大多数是贵格会教徒、门诺会教徒或弟兄会成员，搬进了纪念体育场的南塔，这里将是他们一年的家。许多人在学校里上课，尽管他们的身体变得越来越瘦弱。
The young men became walking scarecrows. Some grew so weak and bony, they couldn't sit without cushions or raise their arms to wash their hair. I remember being a little, a little bit critical of guys that are a part who would lick their plates. I thought that was really pretty crude.
这些年轻人变成了行走的稻草人。有些人虚弱和骨瘦如柴到如果不垫坐垫就无法坐下，或者无法抬起手臂洗头。我记得自己对那些舔盘子的同伴曾有过一点点、一点点批判。我觉得那真的很粗俗。
Henry Schollberg was one of the volunteers. He recalled the experience in the documentary. By the time we ran to about the second month of it, I was doing it myself. You just needed every single calorie you could get your hand on. The results of the starvation experiment were eventually published and remain an important academic reference on nutrition, famine, and eating disorders. But recently, two researchers became intrigued with the 70-year-old study for a completely different reason. They were interested in what the lack of food did, not to the body, but to the mind. I think this type of scarcity is almost like an alarm that goes off in the head,
亨利·肖尔伯格是志愿者之一。他在纪录片中回忆了这段经历。到了大约第二个月的时候，我自己也开始这么做了。你只是需要你能弄到的每一卡路里热量。这项饥饿实验的结果最终得以发表，并成为营养学、饥荒和进食障碍领域的重要学术参考。但最近，两位研究人员出于完全不同的原因对这项已有 70 年历史的研究产生了浓厚兴趣。他们感兴趣的是食物短缺对身体没有影响，而是对心灵产生了什么影响。（注：原文语病，译文顺畅处理）我认为这种稀缺就像是在大脑中拉响警报，
that's saying, hey, we really need this thing addressed. We really need this thing addressed. This is Sandal Moulinathan, a professor of computation and behavioral science at the University of Chicago. He and a colleague, Eldar Schaffer, a psychology professor at Princeton, had a theory brewing. It went like this. When you feel that something important is missing in your life, your brain starts to focus on that missing thing. When you're really desperate for something, you can focus on it so obsessively there's no room for anything else.
在说，嘿，我们真的需要解决这个问题。我们真的需要解决这个问题。这是芝加哥大学计算与行为科学教授森德尔·穆莱纳坦（Sandel Mullainathan）。他和普林斯顿大学心理学教授埃尔达·沙菲尔（Eldar Shafir）同行，孕育了一种理论。它是这样的。当你觉得生活中缺少了某个重要的东西时，你的大脑就会开始聚焦于那个缺失的东西。当你对某样东西极度渴望时，你会执着到无法容纳任何其他东西。
The researchers were just beginning to explore their hypothesis when a colleague mentioned the long ago Minnesota starvation experiment. Elder remembers being immediately fascinated by the study and how the lack of food affected the minds of the men. They basically were very hungry and couldn't stop thinking about eating. In some sense you would think, given that they cannot eat, they'd rather be distracted with other things, but in fact, both subconsciously, the level of immediate reaction
研究人员正准备探讨他们的假设时，一位同事提到了很久以前的明尼苏达饥饿实验。埃尔达回忆说，自己立刻被这项研究以及食物短缺如何影响这些男人的心理深深吸引。他们基本上非常饥饿，满脑子想的都是吃。从某种意义上说，你可能会认为，既然他们吃不到东西，他们宁愿被其他事情转移注意力，但事实上，无论是潜意识里（即时反应的水平）
and their choice of conversation largely was around food. I was actually a sort of tragic comic, I mean, they planned to open restaurants, to become restorators, these memorized recipes, they compared food prices to different newspapers. That's what they were doing, the whole time they sat around looking at food-related issues. Even intentional diversions didn't work.
还是他们的谈话内容，很大程度上都围绕着食物。这其实有点悲喜剧的意思，我是说，他们计划开餐馆，成为餐饮业主，他们背诵食谱，他们在不同的报纸上比对食物价格。他们坐在一起的整个过程，做的都是这些跟食物相关的事。甚至连刻意的消遣也无济于事。
Hunger and food had captured their minds. At some point the experimenters just felt soar for them and decided to distract them with a movie, and some of the testimonials were, they showed me this movie, I couldn't care less about the love scenes I wanted to see the meals. Eldar suddenly realized he had seen the same kind of behavior in a completely different setting. He'd done a lot of research on the effects of poverty and he knew poor people who sometimes behaved like the starving men in Minnesota. The poor people who were lacking financial resources found it very hard to think about
饥饿和食物已经占据了他们的脑海。在某个时刻，实验人员只是为他们感到难过，并决定用电影来分散他们的注意力，一些人的证词是，他们给我看了这部电影，我才不在乎什么爱情场面呢，我只想看饭菜。埃尔达突然意识到，他在一个完全不同的环境中见过这种行为。他对贫穷的影响做了大量研究，他认识一些穷人，他们的行为有时就像明尼苏达州的饥饿男人们一样。那些缺乏经济资源的穷人发现，自己很难去思考
anything but money or at least spend a lot of the cognitive resources, a lot of their attention on financial juggling. found it very hard to think about anything but money, or at least spend a lot of the cognitive resources, a lot of their attention, on financial juggling. If starvation made people obsess over food, poverty made people obsess over how they were going to make ends meet, how to make it to next week. What's in common in both cases is your head is busy with the thing you don't have enough of. The two researchers felt they were on to something.
除了钱以外的任何事情，或者至少把大量的认知资源、大量的注意力花在了金钱周转上。发现自己很难去思考除了钱以外的任何事情，或者至少把大量的认知资源、大量的注意力，花在了金钱周转上。如果饥饿让人对食物痴迷，贫穷则让人对如何维持生计、如何撑到下周痴迷。两者的共同点在于，你的大脑被你严重短缺的东西占满了。这两位研究人员觉得他们有所发现。
Maybe, they thought, the human brain is wired to respond to scarcity by tunneling in on the thing that's missing. Sandel says this makes sense from an evolutionary perspective. Picture that you have somebody from 25,000 years ago who's basically a hunter-gatherer and who might need to do a variety of things such as you know get water do over you know a lot of resources are needed when they get hungry the sort of the evolutionary system wants to have an alarm that says hey really focus on getting food into the system and that I think is the basic scarcity and
他们认为，也许人类的大脑在进化上就是这样设计的：面对稀缺时，会把注意力锁定在缺失的东西上。森德尔说，从进化的角度来看，这是合乎情理的。想象一下，你有一个来自 25,000 年前的祖先，他基本上是个狩猎采集者，可能需要做各种各样的事情，比如你知道的找水源，需要用到大量资源，当他们感到饥饿时，某种进化系统希望发出一个警报，说“嘿，一定要专注于把食物弄到系统里”，而我认为这就是基本的稀缺和
instinct we're hungry and then this thing starts going off in the head saying do you realize we're hungry have Have I mentioned we're hungry? We're hungry, and it just keeps calling out to you. For Brandy Drew, the alarm might have sounded like this. You don't have the necessities your family needs. You need to stock up. Stock up now. You need these things.
本能，我们饿了，然后这个东西开始在大脑里响起，说“你意识到我们饿了吗？我提过我们饿了吗？我们饿了”，它就这样不断地呼唤着你。对布兰迪·德鲁来说，这个警报听起来可能是这样的：你没有家里必需的东西。你需要囤货。马上囤货。你需要这些东西。
And when she bought the bleach, the family sized pack of toilet paper, the snacks and juice boxes for the kids, the alarm temporarily went silent. I felt relieved that those things, the small things I didn't have to worry about. But the reprieve from the alarm came at a huge cost. But then like I said, two days later it's like, okay, wait a minute, why didn't you save at least $100 for gas? The answer to that question,
而当她买下漂白剂、家庭装卫生纸、零食和给孩子们的果汁盒时，警报暂时安静了下来。我感到如释重负，因为那些事情、那些小事我不用再操心了。但警报的暂时解除付出了巨大的代价。但就像我说的，两天后就像是，好吧，等等，你为什么不至少存 100 美元买汽油呢？那个问题的答案，
Sandel and Elder are believe, has to do with what scarcity did to Brandy. She was so focused on getting the basic necessities that she didn't have the mental capacity to attend to anything else. There's a technical term for this. It's called bandwidth. If you're downloading a movie on your home Wi-Fi network, you might find your email runs a little slower. The movie is hogging all the available bandwidth. Send the LNLDR, say our minds, work exactly the same way.
森德尔和埃尔达认为，这与稀缺对布兰迪造成的影响有关。她太专注于获取基本必需品，以至于没有足够的脑力去照顾其他任何事情。这有一个专门的术语。它被称为带宽。如果你在家庭 Wi-Fi 网络上下载电影，你可能会发现你的电子邮件运行得有点慢。这部电影占用了所有可用的带宽。森德尔和埃尔达说，我们的大脑工作方式完全一样。
If your mind is consumed with thoughts about something, there isn't room to think about other stuff. Scarsity fills the mind with intrusive thoughts about what you do not have. It doesn't leave room for anything else. Eldar says there's a simple way to demonstrate this. Imagine trying to hold an eight digit number in your head. And if I simply ask you to keep in mind, you know, two, six, seven, one, seven, one, six, four, that just leaves you less able to attend to other stuff. You eat less well, you pay attention to less things, et cetera. As you're saying that, he did it now and now I, I didn't hear the rest of the next two sentences because I'm trying to remember that. I want to test you. I want to test your promise. But in a sense, that's
如果你的大脑被关于某件事的想法占据了，就没有空间去思考其他事情了。稀缺会让大脑充满关于你所没有的东西的侵入性想法。它不给任何其他东西留空间。埃尔达说，有一个简单的方法可以证明这一点。想象一下，试着把一个八位数记在脑子里。如果我只是请你记住，你知道的，二、六、七、一、七、一、六、四，这只会让你处理其他事情的能力变差。你吃不好，你对事物的注意力变少，等等。当你这么说的时候，他现在做了这个，现在我，我没听到接下来两句的后半部分，因为我在努力记住那个。我想测试你。我想测试你的承诺。但从某种意义上说，这就是
kind of the metaphor. So when you're busy juggling your resources worrying about, you know, how am I going to pay for dinner and if I pay for dinner, will I be able to have money for the kids' school trip? It's that keeping an a-digit number in your head. There's a reason our minds work this way. Tunneling into something makes you focus on it. Everything inside the tunnel becomes crystal clear. The problem is, you can't see anything outside the tunnel. People in the poverty tunnel are actually very good at figuring out how to stretch the
一种隐喻。所以当你忙于周旋你的资源，担心着，你知道的，我怎么付晚饭钱，如果我付了晚饭钱，我还能有钱给孩子们搞学校旅行吗？这就好比在脑子里记着一个八位数。我们的大脑这样运作是有原因的。专注于某事会让你聚焦于它。隧道内部的一切都变得清晰无比。问题在于，你看不见隧道外面的任何东西。处于贫穷隧道中的人们其实非常擅长弄清楚如何将
money they have to make it a tomorrow or the next week. Studies show that the poor tend to be better than the rich at knowing where you can find the best deals, the cheap tube of toothpaste. Someone who is poor is often consumed with finding solutions to immediate problems. How do I get food on the table today? I'm not thinking about problems that are a few weeks away, like the utility bill or gas money or credit card payment. As you're checking the prices and remembering the prices and figuring out if you buy two carrots will you have enough money for breakfast, you are forgetting things you're paying less attention to your rent, to your kids' homework,, all the other things that make your life complete.
手头的钱撑到明天或下周。研究表明，穷人往往比富人更擅长寻找最划算的交易，比如便宜的牙膏。贫穷的人往往一心寻找眼前问题的解决方法。我今天怎么把饭端上桌？我不会去想几周以后的问题，比如水电费、汽油钱或信用卡还款。当你核对价格、记住价格、计算买两根胡萝卜是否有足够的钱吃早餐时，你却在忘记一些事情，你对房租、对孩子的作业、以及所有让你的生活完满的其他事情关注得少了。
The thing is, as a result of doing this, the underlying problem can become worse. If you don't pay your bills, you'll be even deeper in the whole next month. Scarcity, in other words, is a trap. The scarcity trap for us is all those ways in which scarcity today begets behaviors which leads to even further scarcity tomorrow. And we think it's something that poor people do, busy people do. Here's another example. We think to lonely do this. So people who are lonely will often engage in social interactions
关键是，这样做的结果是，潜在的问题可能会变得更糟。如果你不付账单，下个月你就会陷入更深的泥潭。换句话说，稀缺是一个陷阱。对我们而言，稀缺陷阱就是所有这些表现：今天的稀缺引发了种种行为，导致明天更严重的稀缺。而我们认为这是穷人、忙碌的人才会做的事。这里还有另一个例子。我们认为孤独的人也会这样做。所以孤独的人经常会以某种特定方式
in a particular way, which actually makes it harder for them to make friends. Just as the poor focus on the money they do not have, the lonely tend to focus on the friends they do not have. The result is they try too hard to be liked. In a conversation, the lonely person might be so preoccupied with making a good impression that he can't be attention to what's actually being said, the conversation falters. Instead of appearing likable, he's seen as awkward or flat-footed. What happens as a result? People avoid the awkward conversationalist, and the lonely person
进行社交互动，这实际上让他们更难交到朋友。正如穷人关注他们没有的钱一样，孤独的人往往关注他们没有的朋友。结果就是他们过分渴望被人喜欢。在对话中，孤独的人可能会过于全神贯注于留下好印象，以至于无法关注对方实际在说的话，对话便会磕磕绊绊。非但没有显得讨人喜欢，反而被视为笨拙或呆板。结果会怎样呢？人们会避开这个笨拙的谈话者，而孤独的人
becomes even lonelier. This lens offers a new way of thinking about why people who find themselves in scarcity seem to do things that, to an outsider, looks stupid. When you're in a hole, why would you dig yourself even deeper? Sandal says we're asking the wrong question. What if it's not the poor people are somehow deficient, but the poverty makes everyone less capable. That it's you and I tomorrow, where we become poor, what all of a sudden have the same effect. The poverty is in some sense changing our minds.
就会变得更加孤独。这种视角提供了一种新的思考方式：为什么那些陷入稀缺状态的人，在局外人看来会做一些愚蠢的事情。当你身陷泥潭时，为什么还要把自己挖得更深？森德尔说，我们问错了问题。如果不是穷人有什么缺陷，而是贫困让每个人都变得能力不足呢？如果明天你我陷入贫困，也会突然产生同样的效果。从某种意义上说，贫困正在改变我们的思维。
How do we know this isn't some bleeding hot theory to excuse irresponsible behavior? And our Ensenville wanted to test their hypothesis. But if all this is true, one thing that ought to be true is the same person when they're poor should have very different cognitive capacity than when they're rich. So how would we test that?
我们怎么知道这不是某种用来为不负责任行为开脱的空洞理论呢？森德尔和埃尔达想要检验他们的假设。但如果这一切都是真的，有一点应该是真的：同一个人在贫穷时的认知能力应该与富裕时截然不同。那么我们该如何检验这一点呢？
Well, unfortunately, we don't have the kind of money to go around making poor people rich, but sugar cane farmers actually create a natural experiment for us. Yes, sugar cane farmers, specifically those in India who are paid only once a year, right after the harvest. The month after they get that income, they're pretty rich.
嗯，不幸的是，我们没有那种资金去让穷人变富，但甘蔗农实际上为我们创造了一个自然实验。是的，甘蔗农，特别是印度的甘蔗农，他们一年只领一次工资，就在收获后。他们拿到收入的那个月，可以说是相当富裕。
But like anybody who gets a huge windfall all at once, the money gets spent a little too fast. And so, by the end of the harvest cycle cycle they're relatively poor. So now we have the same person, a month before harvest, poor and a month after harvest, well off. Again, you have the same group of people who are poor one moment and rich the next. Send the Linalda, tested the farmers on their long-term thinking when they had no money and when they had plenty of money. when they had no money and when they had plenty of money. The results were stunning. We found a huge difference. So we found that post-harvest when they're well off,
但就像任何一下子获得巨额横财的人一样，钱花得有点太快了。因此，到收获周期的末期，他们相对变得贫穷。现在我们有了同一个人，收获前一个月很穷，收获后一个月很富裕。再次强调，你拥有的是同一群人，他们这一刻很穷，下一刻又很富。森德尔和埃尔达测试了这些农民在身无分文和手头宽裕时的长远思考能力。当他们身无分文和手头宽裕时。结果令人震惊。我们发现了一个巨大的差异。所以我们发现，在收获之后他们手头宽裕时，
they have much more impulse control. Farmers who were rich tended to think about things that would help them over the long term. This matched other research that shows, for example, that farmers who are well off tend to weed their fields more regularly than farmers who are poor. Farmers who are poor mostly focused on how to make it to next week, short term thinking. To be clear, it's not that poor people focus on immediate needs because that's all they
他们的冲动控制力要强得多。富裕的农民倾向于考虑那些能在长远上帮助他们的事。这与其他研究相吻合，例如，研究表明富裕的农民往往比贫穷的农民更经常地给田地除草。贫穷的农民主要关注如何撑到下周，这是短期的思考。需要明确的是，并不是穷人只关注即兴需求，因为那是他们
want to think about. It's all they can think about. Scarsody captures the mind like it did with those starving men in Minnesota. In fact, scarcity can actually lower how you perform on an IQ test. Put simply, being poor is like having just pulled an all-linder. Now, if you've been very lucky, maybe you've never experienced what it's like to be poor, or hungry, or lonely. But, there might be another form of scarcity you have experienced. On some days we get to leave at 4 p.m. some days we don't leave till 1 a.m.
唯一想去想的事情。那是他们唯一能想的事情。稀缺抓住了大脑，就像明尼苏达那些饥饿的人一样。事实上，稀缺实际上会降低你在智商测试中的表现。简而言之，贫穷就像刚熬了个通宵一样。现在，如果你非常幸运，你可能从未体验过贫穷、饥饿或孤独的滋味。但是，你可能体验过另一种形式的稀缺。有时我们下午 4 点下班，有时我们要到凌晨 1 点才离开，
and then you usually start the next day at 5.30 or 6 in the morning. Usually work 80 hours a week. When we come back, how being overworked and exhausted can produce a form of scarcity too and the pernicious effect this can have on your life. Stay with us. Eldar Shaffer and Sendel Muleinathan believe that when something you desperately need is in short supply, your brain tends to focus on that thing. This focus can be so intense that it impedes your ability to think about anything else.
然后你通常在第二天早上 5:30 或 6 点开始上班。通常每周工作 80 小时。稍后回来，我们将探讨过度劳累和精疲力竭如何也会产生一种稀缺，以及它对你生活造成的恶劣影响。请继续收听。埃尔达·沙菲尔和森德尔·穆莱纳坦认为，当你极度需要的东西供应短缺时，你的大脑往往会专注于那件东西。这种专注可能会非常强烈，以至于阻碍你思考其他事情的能力。
What happens when the thing you're missing is time. When you're so busy, it feels like you don't have time to breathe. Let me tell you the story of a young woman named Katie. She asked us to use her middle name for reasons that will be clear in a moment. For as long as she can remember, Katie has been driven, really driven. When I was in high school, I was determined to be valedictorian, so I took a sophomore level honors biology course as a freshman in high school, and I studied around the clock. I had note cards. I walked through the hallways with the note cards. If there was a holiday party, I brought the note cards.
当缺少的正是时间时，会发生什么呢？当你忙得连喘口气的时间都没有时。让我给你们讲一个年轻女性凯蒂的故事。由于原因待会儿就会明了，她请我们使用她的中间名。记忆中，凯蒂一直是个很有进取心的人，真的非常有进取心。我在高中时，就决心要成为毕业典礼致辞代表，所以我在高一的时候就上了一个高二水平的荣誉生物课，我夜以继日地学习。我有小卡片。我拿着小卡片走在走廊里。如果有节日派对，我也带着小卡片。
And I had also studied till two or three in the morning. Katie says she wanted to be perfect at school. She eventually got to medical school, where she excelled. She graduated at the top of her class and quickly started her residency. The new schedule was grueling. You can get in at 5.30 or 6 in the morning and you round on all your patients and then you round with the team. That means you go to all the patients and check in on their plan and adjust medications, etc. as necessary.
我还一直学到凌晨两三点。凯蒂说她想在学校里做到完美。她最终进入了医学院，在那里表现优异。她以优异的成绩毕业，并迅速开始了自己的住院医师实习。新的时间表极其折磨人。你早上 5:30 或 6 点到医院，查房看所有的病人，然后和团队一起查房。这意味着你要去所有的病人那里，查看他们的治疗方案并根据需要调整药物等。
And then there's usually a lunch conference where we have education and then in the afternoon we might take new patients in and keep following up on our patients. And on some days we get to leave at 4 p.m. some days we don't leave till 1 a.m. So and then you usually start the next day at 5.30 or 6 in the morning again. And you get one day off a week. Usually work 80 hours is a week. As Katie's workload grew she started to feel she couldn't afford to waste a single moment. Instead of spending any time relaxing, she started to focus only on things
然后通常会有一个午餐会议，我们会有教育培训，然后在下午我们可能会接收新病人并继续跟进我们的病人。有些日子我们下午 4 点就可以离开，有些日子我们要到凌晨 1 点才离开。所以，通常第二天早上又得在 5:30 或 6 点开始工作。而且你一周只有一天假。通常每周工作 80 个小时。随着凯蒂的工作量增加，她开始觉得她连一分一秒都浪费不起。她不再把任何时间花在放松上，而是开始只专注于
directly related to her success at work. When I first started, it was just really busy, so I tried to come home and I felt like, you know, I just don't have a lot of hours, so I need to make the most of them. And I was like, okay, I need to make sure I'm exercising, keeping my body healthy, and I need to read and stay on top of things. So I come home after a pretty long day, and I might go walking for half an hour, and then I'd read, and then I go to sleep. But then as the time went on, I decided to try to get in more exercise, because then I never know when I'll get enough exercise in. So I started spending all my free daylight hours walking or running outside or going to the gym up to three hours a day plus like working 15 hour days and then trying to read and then go to sleep. As she focused intensely on
与她在工作中取得成功直接相关的事情。刚开始的时候，事情真的很多，所以我试着回家，我觉得，你知道的，我没有很多时间，所以我需要充分利用它们。我想，好吧，我得确保我在锻炼，保持身体健康，我需要阅读并掌握最新动态。所以我度过了相当漫长的一天后回家，可能会散步半小时，然后阅读，然后去睡觉。但后来随着时间的推移，我决定尝试进行更多锻炼，因为我永远不知道什么时候才能得到足够的锻炼。所以我开始把所有空闲的白天时间都用来在外面散步、跑步，或者去健身房，每天长达三个小时，再加上工作 15 小时，然后试图阅读，然后睡觉。由于高度专注于
the things she believed were key to her professional success, Katie lost sight of things on the periphery. success. Katie lost sight of things on the periphery. She didn't know it, but she was entering the tunnel of scarcity. In her case, it was scarcity brought on by a lack of time. So I wasn't going to the grocery store. My house wasn't unpacked yet and it was stressing me out. And it was just a mess. And my clothes piled up. I had a lot of dirty clothes and coming home just felt so overwhelming. I didn't want to be there. And that's part of, I think, why I was walking so much just to get out of the house and get away from all the things I hadn't done.
那些她认为对职业成功至关重要的事，凯蒂忽略了边缘的事情。成功。凯蒂忽视了边缘的事物。她当时并不知道，但她正在进入稀缺的隧道。就她而言，那是由于缺乏时间引起的稀缺。所以我没有去杂货店。我的房子还没拆包，这让我压力很大。那一团糟。我的衣服堆成了山。我有很多脏衣服，回到家感觉太压抑了。我不想呆在那里。我想这也是为什么我走那么多路只是为了离开家，远离所有我还没做完的事情的部分原因。
And I also forgot to pay a bill in the mix of all of this. What did you forget to do? What bill did you forget to pay? It was my energy bill. The old Katie would have spotted all of this. I mean, you were just basically at this point almost falling apart, it sounds like. I was.
在这期间我还忘记付账单了。你忘了做什么？你忘了付什么账单？是我的电费账单。以前的凯蒂本来会注意到这一切的。我是说，听起来你当时基本上快要崩溃了。我确实崩溃了。
I was falling apart. There was something else. Katie had battled anorexia as a teenager. She knew she had to stay vigilant about her eating. But as she started to focus ever more intensely on work, she slipped back into some old habits. I was eating mostly vegetables and fruits, and I wasn't eating a whole lot else, maybe a cliff bar here and there.
我快崩溃了。还有一件事。凯蒂在青少年时期曾与神经性厌食症做过斗争。她知道自己必须对饮食保持警惕。但随着她开始更专心致志地投入工作，她又滑回了一些旧习惯。我主要吃蔬菜和水果，没有吃很多别的东西，可能偶尔吃一根克里夫能量棒。
Despite all her medical training, Katie stopped taking care of herself. Here's one thing I haven't told you yet about scarcity. It can rob you of insight, insight about how your own mind is changing. Katie had no awareness that she was heading down a dangerous path. It became obvious to her only when it finally affected her work. I started to notice that I was like nearly missing things. As I was reviewing, for example, I admitted a diabetic and I almost didn't order insulin for them, but I did order the insulin.
尽管受过所有的医学训练，凯蒂还是停止了照顾自己。关于稀缺，我还有一件事没告诉你。它会剥夺你的洞察力，剥夺关于你自己的大脑正在如何改变的洞察力。凯蒂完全没有意识到自己正在走向一条危险的道路。直到它最终影响到她的工作，她才幡然醒悟。我开始注意到我几乎漏掉了事情。比如我在复查时，我收治了一个糖尿病患者，我差点没给他开胰岛素，但我最后还是开了。
But I was like, I don't think I can keep up with this anymore because if you don't give a diabetic insulin, especially if they're type one, they can have very fatal circumstances in the hospital and get really high blood sugars that can cause them to have an acidosis and end up on a ventilator. So, I turned myself in at the point that I saw that it was starting to affect my work. In two months of the residency program, Katie's body and mind had withered. Things had gotten so bad she had to go to a residential treatment center. Kati struggled with two things. Her body was desperately in need of nutrition.
但我想，我再也无法承受这个了，因为如果你不给糖尿病患者胰岛素，特别是当他们是一型糖尿病时，在医院里可能会产生非常致命的后果，导致血糖极高，从而引发酸中毒并最终用上呼吸机。所以，当我发现它开始影响我的工作时，我主动自首了。在住院医师项目的两个月里，凯蒂的身体和精神都枯萎了。事情变得如此糟糕，她不得不去一家住院治疗中心。凯蒂面临着两件棘手的事情。她的身体急需营养。
And her mind, she had to find a way to stop the intrusive thoughts that were consuming her. She had to... Learn how to just sit, because we weren't allowed to exercise, we weren't allowed to stand, we weren't even allowed to do jumping jacks or squats, we had to just sit, because we weren't allowed to exercise, we weren't allowed to stand, we weren't even allowed to do jumping jacks or squats, we had to just sit. Katie's mind was filled with angry and impatient thoughts. At first, I felt like I felt useless because I thought, you know, if I'm not doing something productive, what is my purpose in life.
而她的精神，她必须找到一种方法来停止那些消耗着她的侵入性想法。她必须……学会如何只是坐着，因为我们不准运动，不准站立，甚至不准做开合跳或深蹲，我们只能坐着，因为我们不准运动，不准站立，甚至不准做开合跳或深蹲，我们只能坐着。凯蒂的脑子里充满了愤怒和不耐烦的想法。起初，我觉得自己很没用，因为我想，你知道的，如果我没有做一些有生产力的事，我生命的意义何在。
But gradually, as the program literally forced her to do nothing, Katie started to emerge from the tunnel. She realized she had been so narrowly, relentlessly focused on one goal, doing well at work, that she'd ignored the very things she needed to succeed, moments of relaxation, like watching TV, or in her case, painting. Katie had loved art as a child, but she had put it aside because she thought it wouldn't help her become a better doctor. I'm kind of the type of person that just likes to study and then do after I've like mastered it from a
但渐渐地，当这个项目从字面意义上迫使她什么也不做时，凯蒂开始走出隧道。她意识到自己曾如此狭隘、无情地专注于一个目标——在工作中表现出色——以至于她忽略了成功所必需的东西：片刻的放松，比如看电视，或者对她来说，画画。凯蒂小时候很喜欢艺术，但她把它放在了一边，因为她认为这对她成为一名更好的医生没有帮助。我属于那种喜欢学习，然后等我从
studies point of view and so to just do something without instruction is it feels very vulnerable to me but it ended up kind of being my saving grace in my recovery. And I've actually created an art room in my house. I changed my office from a work room into an art room. And it has paints and watercolors and chocks and everything you can imagine. And I try to go in there once a week and just create something without any expectation just for the purpose of creating it because I can. Katie eventually returned to her residency program with a new outlook.
学习的角度掌握了之后再去实践的人，所以不经指导就去做一件事让我觉得非常脆弱，但它最终算是我康复过程中的救命稻草。我实际上在家里创建了一个艺术室。我把办公室从工作室改造成了一个艺术室。里面有颜料、水彩、粉笔和你能想象到的一切。我尽量每周去一次，不抱任何期望地创作点东西，纯粹为了创作而创作，因为我能。凯蒂最终以崭新的面貌回到了她的住院医师项目。
She started doing something that Eldar and Sender recommend to all busy people. She actually pencils time into our schedule to do nothing. One of the big things I've done is I kind of have a date night with myself once or twice a week, where I just schedule off the night and I won't do anything with anyone else and they'll just be free for me to do what I feel like. It might be watching a movie, it might be taking a soak in the tub and reading a book, or being in my art room and painting whatever comes to me. But I do, like, I prioritize that, and I actually won't accept plans with friends generally
她开始做一件埃尔达和森德尔向所有大忙人推荐的事。她实际上在日程表里腾出时间来什么也不做。我做的一件大事就是，我每周和自己进行一两次所谓的约会，我会把那个晚上空出来，不和任何人做任何事，那段时间完全由我支配，随心所欲。可能是看部电影，可能是泡个澡读本书，或者待在我的艺术室里，画任何涌上心头的东西。但我确实这样做了，我把这放在首位，而且通常
when I do this. So that's one of the things I do. Katie is consciously freeing up bandwidth. And something strange has happened as she's done so. The less consumed she feels about work, the better she does at work. Honestly, like, it's kind of incredible, but at work, the better she does at work. Honestly, it's kind of incredible, but at work, my brain has increased its capacity for fold.
这样做的时候我不会接受朋友的安排。所以这是我做的事情之一。凯蒂正在有意识地释放带宽。随着她这么做，奇怪的事情发生了。她对工作的焦虑感越少，她在工作中的表现就越好。老实说，这有点不可思议，但在工作中，她的工作表现反而更好。老实说，这有点不可思议，但在工作中，我的大脑容量成倍增加了。
I am able to hold so many more things in my consciousness at once and manage them. I've just seen a really huge improvement in my ability to enjoy being in the company of others, to enjoy occasions and to enjoy my work and do well at my work. While the psychological studies into scarcity and bandwidth are relatively new, the ideas are actually ancient. Avoid tunnel vision, keep difficult things in one part of your life from contaminating everything else. Be present. Say you have a big deadline tomorrow for something you've got to finish.
我能够在意识中同时容纳更多的事情并对它们进行管理。我真的看到我的能力有了巨大的提升，无论是享受与他人相处的陪伴、享受活动，还是享受工作并把工作做好。虽然关于稀缺和带宽的心理学研究相对较新，但这些理念其实由来已久。避免隧道视野，防止生活中某个部分的棘手问题污染其他一切。活在当下。假设你明天有一个必须完成的重要截止日期。
You go home and you're spending the evening with your kids. And in that moment, you're not present-focused at all. What you're focused on is that deadline. You may go through minutes where you didn't hear what your kids were saying to you, because your mind keeps going to this other thing. Tonervision is not in itself a good thing or a bad thing. Shutting out distractions can be helpful at times. The question is, do you know when you're inside the tunnel? To me, that's exactly the heart of managing scarcity.
你回家和孩子们共度傍晚。在那一刻，你一点也没有专注于当下。你关注的是那个截止日期。你可能会有好几分钟根本没听进孩子们对你说的话，因为你的大脑一直想着别的事情。隧道视野本身并不是一件好事或坏事。屏蔽干扰有时会有所帮助。问题是，你知道自己什么时候身处隧道之中吗？对我来说，这正是管理稀缺的核心。
It's recognizing when are you trying to do something related to your scarcity or you really want to use that instinct. And when have you made a conscious decision to do something else? Where what you really need to do is to not have it in fruit on that something else. You're at home, you're with your kids, you chose to be a parent for that three hour period. You really don't want scarcity to improve then. Of course, it's easy to say, build free time into your schedule. Stay present with your family.
它在于识别：你什么时候在做与稀缺相关的事情，或者你真的很想利用那种本能？而你什么时候做出了有意识的决定去做别的事？此时你真正需要做的是不要让它侵扰其他事情。你在家，你和孩子们在一起，在那三个小时里你选择当一个父母。你真的不希望稀缺在那时发挥作用。当然，说起来容易，在日程表中安排出自由时间。与家人共度当下。
Take a vacation. These strategies presume you have choices. You can't say I've had it with being lonely. I'm going to take a vacation from being lonely. It's not a choice. And to me, loneliness and poverty are the forms of scarcity, the feel the biggest, because while all these forces are at play, there's no release valve.
去度假。这些策略的前提是你还有选择。你不能说我受够了孤独。我要请个假摆脱孤独。这不是一种选择。对我来说，孤独和贫穷是表现得最强烈的稀缺形式，因为当所有这些力量在起作用时，却没有释放阀。
There's no escape mechanism. Elder and Sendoal want policy makers to design solutions that recognize how scarcity creates traps from which many people may not be able to extricate themselves. And they want the rest of us to stop preaching to those in poverty. If you look at programs at poverty, we often confound a little bit the attempts to help the poor with the attempts to educate them. Make sure that they show up in time, that they do the right things. From the perspective, we're taking with scarcity,
没有逃生机制。埃尔达和森德尔希望政策制定者设计出能够认识到稀缺如何制造陷阱的解决方案，许多人可能无法靠自己摆脱这些陷阱。他们希望我们其余的人停止向处于贫穷中的人说教。如果你看看有关贫困的项目，我们经常把帮助穷人的努力与教育他们的努力混为一谈。确保他们准时出现，做正确的事。从我们对稀缺所采取的视角来看，
in some sense, if I'm very busy juggling a very complicated life, insisting that I show up at the office at 8 and not 805. It's not doing me a favor, I don't need to be educated, it's just hard to manage. The transportation is not reliable, my kid is not ready, I don't have a babysitter, I'm going to make mistakes that it's not clear educating me in quotes about them is going to help me at all, it just makes my life all the more complicated. When people in poverty fail or make mistakes, the researchers think we should respond to them the same way we respond to mistakes made by airline pilots.
从某种意义上说，如果我忙得不可开交，生活一团糟，还非得要求我8点整而不是8点零五分到办公室，这根本不是在帮我。我不需要被教育，这只是管理起来很难。交通不可靠，孩子没准备好，没有保姆，我会犯错，而所谓对我进行一番“教育”是否真有帮助也未可知，这只会让我的生活更加复杂。当身处贫困的人失败或犯错时，研究人员认为我们应该以对待飞行员犯错相同的方式来对待他们。
There was a time not long ago when we thought that airline pilots who made mistakes were just bad pilots. Sandal says a big reason air travel has become safer in recent decades is that there has been a shift in thinking about such mistakes. Designers have made cockpits fault tolerant. Rather than trying to find perfect pilots, cockpits are now designed to account for human error. The goal is to alert pilots when they've made a mistake and to diminish the consequences of mistakes. It's ironic that when we design cockpits, the entire mantra of fault tolerance seems so
就在不久前，我们还认为犯错的飞行员只是糟糕的飞行员。桑德尔表示，近几十年来航空旅行变得更安全的一个重要原因，是人们对这类错误的看法发生了转变。设计人员让驾驶舱具备了容错能力。驾驶舱不再试图寻找完美的飞行员，而是旨在应对人为失误。其目的是在飞行员犯错时发出警报，并减轻错误的后果。具有讽刺意味的是，当我们设计驾驶舱时，容错的整个信条似乎是如此
intuitive, but when we design social policies, nobody's out there talking about, let's make this fault tolerant. I mean, you know, poor people have a lot on their mind, they're bandwidth attacks, they're going to make mistakes. Let's make sure this program is robust when they do make that mistake. It's just not the way we think. If I offer a training program, I don't sit there and say, uh, let me make sure, you know what's going to happen? This is for low income individuals. Surely they're going to miss a few days because, you know, it's hard to get to class sometimes or other things around their mind. So let me design this curriculum so that it's in attendance tolerant. So even if somebody misses three days in a row, they'll be able to come on that fourth day and still feel caught up. In fact, a training curriculum is often quite
直观，但当我们设计社会政策时，却没有人出来谈论，让我们把这个设计得具有容错能力吧。我的意思是，你知道的，穷人脑子里装了很多事情，他们正遭受带宽攻击，他们难免会犯错。让我们确保这个项目在他们犯错时依然稳健。我们根本不会这样思考。如果我提供一个培训项目，我不会坐在那里说，呃，让我确保，你知道会发生什么吗？这是面向低收入人群的。他们肯定会缺席几天，因为你知道，有时候很难去上课，或者脑子里还有其他事情。所以让我把这个课程设计成具有出勤容错性的。这样，即使某人连续缺席三天，他们也能在第四天来上课时仍然觉得能跟上进度。事实上，培训课程往往
the opposite. If you miss three days in a row, it's an invitation to Mr. Ford Day. You're not going to get anything. Brandy Drew eventually turned her life around. She found a low-income assistance program that offered her help. She walked with a financial counselor who gave her strategies for budgeting her money and keeping track of long-term priorities. I actually have a calendar now that I write down everything to make sure I'm paying things on the correct day and time. It's taken time and little steps, but Brandy is no longer in the scarcity tunnel.
恰恰相反。如果你连续缺席三天，那就是在请你第四天也别来了。你什么也学不到。布兰迪·德鲁最终扭转了她的人生。她找到了一个为她提供帮助的低收入援助项目。她与一位财务顾问一起，获得了预算资金和关注长期优先事项的策略。我现在确实有一个日历，上面写着所有的东西，以确保我在正确的日期和时间支付账单。这需要时间和一点点的步伐，但布兰迪不再处于短缺地道中了。
She's been working for two years now, and she has savings. I know that if anything happens, God forbid if I lose this job, I know that I can survive for at least six months if I have to look for another. El Doran send though themselves, say, I can survive for at least six months if I have to look for another. Eldor and Sendo themselves say they are constantly trying to keep the lessons of scarcity front and center in their own lives.
她现在已经工作两年了，而且有了积蓄。我知道如果发生任何事情，上帝保佑，如果我失去这份工作，我知道如果我必须寻找另一份工作，我至少可以维持六个月的生活。埃尔达·沙菲尔和森德希尔本人也表示，他们不断努力将“短缺”带来的教训放在自己生活的显眼和核心位置。
As a busy academic, Eldor has come up with a rule. When an invitation to an event two months down the road comes along, he asks himself whether he would attend the event if it were tomorrow. If the answer is no, he declines the invitation because his life is not going to be any less hectic two months from now. Preserving bandwidth takes conscious effort. Most of us, Eldar included, are going to violate the Eldar rule. We'll say yes to new commitments when we don't have the time
作为一名忙碌的学者，埃尔达想出了一个规则。当两个月后的某个活动邀请到来时，他会问自己，如果这个活动是在明天，他是否会去参加。如果答案是否定的，他就会拒绝邀请，因为从现在算起两个月后，他的生活并不会变得不那么忙碌。保持带宽需要有意识的努力。我们大多数人，包括埃尔达在内，都会违反埃尔达规则。当我们在没有时间的时候，会对新的承诺说“好”
or pull out a credit card when we can't afford it. In those moments, it's important to look up. To notice, we are inside a tunnel. This episode was produced by Jenny Schmidt and Maggie Penman. It was edited by Tara Boyle. We had original music this week from Ramteen Arabliwi. Our team includes Raina Cohen, Laura Quarell, Thomas Liu and Parth Shah. Our unsung hero this week is Sung Kim. Sung is a senior director with the
或者在买不起的时候掏出信用卡。在那些时刻，抬起头来很重要。去注意到，我们正身处地道之中。本集由珍妮·施密特和玛吉·彭曼制作。由塔拉·博伊尔编辑。本周的原创音乐来自拉姆廷·阿拉布利维。我们的团队包括雷娜·科恩、劳拉·夸雷尔、托马斯·刘和帕特·沙阿。我们本周的无名英雄是金松。金松是
local initiative Support Coalition. This is a national group that supports financial opportunity centers around the country, including the one in Detroit that helped Brandi Drew get back on her feet. Song got us in touch with Brandi after making numerous calls and reaching out to friends, colleagues and counselors. Sometimes the people whose stories need telling can be hard to find. Song helped us to bridge that gap. For more hidden brain, you can follow us to bridge that gap. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
地方倡议支持联盟的高级总监。这是一个全国性组织，支持全国各地的金融机会中心，包括底特律帮助布兰迪·德鲁重新站起来的那个中心。金在打了无数个电话并联系了朋友、同事和顾问后，帮我们联系上了布兰迪。有时，那些需要讲述其故事的人可能很难找到。金帮我们弥合了这一差距。想了解更多隐形大脑节目，你可以关注我们... 目前本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。